Pour de nombreuses tâches, l'humain reste plus performant que la machine. Mais au fil des siècles les machines n'ont cessé de rattraper leur retard.
Et ce n'est pas étonnant.
Les machines sont plus puissantes physiquement, elles peuvent stocker l'information de manière plus fiable, plus durable et en plus grande quantité,
elles sont capables de communiquer à travers le monde en quelques millisecondes et avec un débit d'information énorme
et surtout les machines calculent vite, elles calculent même super vite.
Pendant que mon cerveau de primate galère à faire plus de deux ou trois opérations par seconde, mon téléphone peut en effectuer des milliards.
Ceci dit, pour l'instant, certaines facultés humaines, comme le bon sens, la créativité ou la capacité d'apprentissage,
demeurent hors de portée des machines. Pour l'instant !
Mais depuis quelques années une révolution semble s'être mise en place
et cette révolution a été incarnée par un algorithme d'apprentissage appelé le deep learning.
En particulier, en 2012, le deep learning a stupéfait tout le monde de la recherche
en explosant les performances de toutes les autres méthodes dans une compétition de reconnaissance d'objets sur une image.
Alors que les autres méthodes plafonnaient à un taux d'erreur de 25%, le deep learning réussit à faire chuter ce taux à 16% !
Sauf que le deep learning de 2012, ce n'était qu'un premier jet.
L'année suivante, toutes les meilleures équipes s'étaient mises au deep learning :
les taux d'erreur chutèrent à  14 ; 7,3 ; 6,6 puis 5,7 %
Plus étonnant encore : le deep learning est désormais surhumain en reconnaissance d'image.
Autrement dit, si vous croyez voir un fantôme et si le deep learning, champion d'Image Net, dit qu'il s'agit de fumée,
je vais davantage faire confiance au deep learning.
Alors, je dis ça sur le ton de la blague, avec un exemple un peu débile,
mais il s'agit en fait là de quelque chose d'incroyablement profond et dont les conséquences sociétales vont être énormes.
Années après années, l'ensemble des tâches où l'humain surpasse la machine, fond comme neige au soleil.
Après les échecs en 1997,
les machines se sont mises à surpasser les meilleurs d'entre nous à tout plein d'autres jeux, que ce soit jeopardy, le jeu de go ou le poker.
D'autres machines ont su apprendre à jouer aux jeux vidéo d'Atari ou à des jeux comme Super Mario World,
Mario Kart ou Dota 2, et atteindre des performances souvent surhumaines.
Et ce qu'il y a d'impressionnant pour ces jeux, c'est que les machines sont parties de rien !
Au moment de prendre les commandes, tout ce qu'elles voyaient, c'était les couleurs des pixels à l'écran
Les machines ont elles-mêmes appris les règles de ces jeux, puis les bonnes stratégies à suivre.
Alors! ... Les machines "gameuses", a priori, c'est pas ça qui va bouleverser nos sociétés !
En revanche on ne peut pas en dire autant d'autres machines qui se sont affairées à remplacer le travail humain, à commencer par les véhicules autonomes.
Cela fait déjà plusieurs années que de nombreuses voitures autonomes sillonnent les routes aux quatre coins du monde.
Les voitures Tesla ont même déjà un système autonome sur autoroute, que les usagers peuvent activer.
Depuis 2015 en France, la législation autorise la circulation de voitures entièrement autonomes, dans le cadre de procédures de test.
Et le 2 octobre dernier, en 2017, quatre Renault Zoé électriques autonomes ont circulé à Rouen.
Plus surprenant encore, Jean-Louis Missika, adjoint de la maire de Paris,
affirme que des opérateurs prévoient déjà d'expérimenter des taxis autonomes, dès 2018.
Et en fait, ça fait déjà plus d'un an que des bus autonomes sont en fonctionnement aux quatre coins du monde.
Alors oui ! ces véhicules autonomes ne sont pas et ne seront jamais parfaits, mais la question, ce n'est pas de savoir s'ils seront parfaits !
Il s'agit de savoir s'ils seront meilleurs que des conducteurs humains.
Or les conducteurs humains sont, en fait, super mauvais.
En 2016, 3477 sont mortes par accident de la route sur les routes françaises.
Du coup, si les véhicules autonomes sont, ne serait-ce, que deux fois moins létals que les conducteurs humains,
ne pas les légaliser reviendrait à tuer des milliers de personnes par an ; et ce, rien qu'en France.
Sauf que bien sûr légaliser les véhicules autonomes, c'est aussi mettre fin à de nombreux métiers du transport.
Des centaines de milliers de jobs sont directement menacés, sans compter ceux qui dépendent indirectement de l'industrie du transport.
D'où l'urgence de repenser notre système de redistribution des richesses.
D'autant que les métiers du transport ne sont pas la seule cible des machines.
Managers, ingénieurs, médecins, avocats, artistes, chercheurs, professeurs, et même youtubeurs,
tous semblent voués à être surpassés par les machines.
D'ailleurs, certains métiers qualifiés ont déjà partiellement disparu.
C'est le cas, par exemple, des traders dont le cœur de métier a déjà été essentiellement remplacé par des machines.
Eh oui, parce que ces machines sont capables d'acheter et de vendre bien avant qu'un trader humain n'ait eu le temps de cligner de l’œil.
Les machines ont conquis les entrepôts d'Amazon ; elles se sont mis à construire des maisons et des ponts,
ainsi qu'à planter des légumes et à les faire pousser.
Et je ne pense pas avoir besoin de mentionner les productions à la chaîne :
le métier d'ouvrier est en train de partir en fumée,
non pas parce que les entreprises sont d'horribles monstres, qui préfèrent licencier leurs employés plutôt que les exploiter,
mais parce que les "incentives" à l'automatisation sont énormes !
Les machines sont plus rapides, plus fiables, et beaucoup moins chères.
Elles ne se plaignent jamais et ne sont jamais en grève.
Elles permettent de produire en quantité et en qualité, à un coup ridiculement faible.
Mais ce n'est là qu'un début !
Contrairement à une idée reçue, même dans des métiers qui semblent requérir un jugement subjectif, que l'on pourrait croire nécessairement humain,
la machine surpasse, lentement mais sûrement, les compétences humaines.
La "goal line technology" a conquis le monde du football, bien que celui-ci ait longtemps résisté aux technologies.
Et il n'est pas inconcevable qu'un jour les arbitres soient remplacés par des machines, dont on pourra plus facilement garantir l'impartialité.
D'ailleurs, cette mécanisation de l'arbitrage a déjà commencé dans le monde de la gymnastique.
Les métiers du droit pourrait suivre cette tendance aussi.
On l'a vu: côté juge, les biais sont énormes... à commencer par le fait que le juge ait bien mangé ou non
Remplacer les juges par des machines pourrait là aussi garantir davantage d'impartialité,
d'autant que les progrès des machines dans ce domaine sont énormes. Mais ce n'est pas tout...
la machine Case Cruncher a ainsi battu les humains dans une compétition de prédiction de l'issue d'un processus légal.
Pendant ce temps, à JP Morgan,
ce sont 360 000 heures de travail humain d'avocats qu'une machine a su effectuer en seulement quelques secondes,
et ce avec une fiabilité supérieure à celle des avocats humains.
Une autre machine encore, appelée "do not pay" vous donne dès aujourd'hui des conseils juridiques pour éviter de payer des amendes de stationnement.
Selon son créateur, cette machine a réussi à annuler 375 000 amendes en l'espace de deux ans.
L'industrie du droit représente des milliards d'euros par an.
Une large proportion de cette industrie pourrait disparaître dans les années à venir.
Les machines deviendront aussi nos médecins de demain.
Certains machines "chirurgiens" sont d'ores et déjà beaucoup plus fiables que les chirurgiens humains.
Mais surtout, le gros du travail du médecin est le diagnostic médical,
qui consiste à analyser des symptômes et des données physiologiques pour inférer les maladies probables.
Or des machines ont déjà surpassé l'humain dans le diagnostic de plusieurs maladies,
comme le cancer de la peau à partir d'une photo, ou celui des arythmies cardiaques.
Mieux encore, les machines du futur pourront accéder à bien d'autres données auxquelles les médecins d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas accès,
que ce soit la concentration, en temps réel dans notre sang, en glucose, en cholestérol ou en d'autres produits chimiques
mais aussi les dernières avancées de la recherche médicale.
Alors on pourrait croire que ces machines seront incapables de faire preuve d'empathie ou de contact humain,
sauf que les machines ont en fait déjà surpassé les humains, dans l'analyse des sentiments d'autrui à partir de son visage.
Les machines seront davantage capables de s'adapter à notre humeur
et ainsi nous aider à nous remonter le moral ou à délivrer au mieux une mauvaise nouvelle.
Et oui ! on a tendance à oublier à quel point on est mauvais quand il s'agit de comprendre ce que l'autre ressent ou subit.
Notamment lorsque l'hooligan en nous surgit !  Ce n'est donc pas si difficile de faire mieux que l'humain.
De la même manière, on a tendance à penser que seul l'humain est capable de ressentir l'élégance des oeuvres artistiques.
Sauf que dans ce domaine aussi la machine est en train d'atteindre des performances surhumaines.
Typiquement, la musique que vous entendez en ce moment,
c'est une musique composée et jouée par une machine appelée JukeDeck et ce gratuitement et en exclusivité pour cette vidéo.
Les machines ont aussi appris à peindre et à dessiner, voire à reconnaître nos dessins.
Mieux encore : une machine appelée DeepArt est capable de combiner n'importe laquelle de vos photos
avec le style d'un grand peintre pour ainsi créer une œuvre d'art inédite.
Face aux progrès spectaculaires des machines, de nombreux observateurs se sont mis à encourager l'éducation de masse,
pour acquérir des compétences encore inaccessibles aux machines.
Sauf qu'à bien y réfléchir, même des métiers qui nécessitent des décennies d'études ne sont pas immunisés contre les machines
De nos jours les machines sont partout dans les sciences,
de la recherche de molécules pour soigner des maladies
à l'analyse des données des accélérateurs de particules,
en passant par la reconstitution des circuits du cerveau humain
ou par l'observation des profondeurs du cosmos.
Les informaticiens sont même en train de chercher à doter leurs machines de capacités à prouver des théorèmes
et de nombreuses preuves sont d'ores et déjà largement assistées par des machines aux compétences surhumaines.
Et les informaticiens ne s'arrêtent pas là. Ils cherchent même à automatiser leur propre métier
en dotant leurs machines de capacités à générer leur propre code, étant donné par exemple une simple spécification de ce que le code doit faire.
Ou encore ils dotent leurs machines de capacité à réparer d'autres machines voire à s'auto-réparer.
Même les métiers de chercheurs et de développeurs pourraient un jour être automatisés,
et il en va de même de celui de youtubeur.
Au Japon, une combinaison d'une machine et d'humains a ainsi déjà réussi à soumettre un manuscrit récompensé par des humains.
L'écriture de scripts, qui est le gros de mon boulot sur Youtube, pourrait donc bientôt être automatisé.
Reste à passer devant la caméra me direz-vous, mais là encore les progrès sont spectaculaires.
La machine WaveNet de Google est ainsi capable de synthétiser des voix indiscernables de voix naturelles...
The Blue Lagoon is a 1980 american romance and adventure film, directed by  Randal Kleiser.
...tandis que des technologies permettent de caler une voix à une image, même si la voix ne correspond pas à l'image.
Texte en anglais
Plus troublant encore, il est désormais possible de fabriquer en temps réel une image de n'importe qui, prononçant n'importe quel discours.
Et si vous ne disposez pas de bonne image de la personne en question, pas de souci
d'autres machines sont capables d'améliorer la résolution d'images pourtant très pixélisées.
Whoua, tout ça donne le vertige. Mais vers quel monde se dirige-t-on ?
En fait, si le futur que je dépeins nous paraît si différent du présent,
c'est surtout parce qu'on a tendance à mal se rendre compte à quel point le monde a déjà changé au cours des dernières décennies.
Aujourd'hui les machines nous ont encerclés. Les algorithmes de Facebook, Youtube et Netflix décident en grande partie de ce que nous lisons et regardons.
Gmail va même jusqu'à décider de masquer automatiquement les spams, tandis que Google est notre porte d'entrée au monde de l'internet,
et même ce que nous écrivons est suggéré par l'auto complétion de nos téléphones.
Les machines se chargent aussi de planifier des rencontres amoureuses,
d'affecter des étudiants à des formations post-bac,
de suggérer des candidats pour des postes en entreprise à pourvoir,
ou encore de gérer ce qui auparavant était un énorme bordel administratif.
Les machines ont déjà envahi notre quotidien et personne n'a vraiment le contrôle de cette invasion.
Alors dis comme ça, ça peut paraître effrayant,
mais il faut aussi voir que l'on cède en fait volontiers le pouvoir aux machines.
Et ça c'est parce que dans de nombreux cas, qu'il s'agisse de ce que Youtube nous suggère, de ce que Gmail classe dans les spams,
ou des véhicules autonomes qui nous ramèneront chez nous quand on sera complètement saouls,
ces machines nous rendent service.
Et la clé pour nous rendre service, c'est la recherche en intelligence artificielle et en machine learning.
Alors il y a un débat récurrent que de déterminer la différence entre les deux.
Franchement perso je dirais osef.
J'aime bien notamment la remarque de Will Wilson :
c'est de l'intelligence artificielle pour lever des fonds, et du machine learning pour recruter.
Par contre une distinction qui me semble importante à faire
est celle entre recherche appliquée et recherche théorique.
Le problème des applications aujourd'hui, c'est que tout va très très très très vite
et que du coup ce qui est l'état de l'art aujourd'hui peut tout à fait devenir obsolète dans un an.
Donc dans cette série, et contrairement à ce qu'on a fait dans ce premier épisode,
on va surtout parler des aspects théoriques de l'intelligence artificielle,
de sorte que les prochains épisodes resteront valables et pertinents, je l'espère, dans cinq, dix, ou vingt ans.
Pour ce faire, je vais surtout m'appuyer sur deux livres :
le livre "Understanding machine learning, from theory to algorithms" de Shaley-Shwartz et Ben-David,
et le livre "Deep Learning" de Benjio, Goodfellow et Courville.
Et puis dans les premiers épisodes de cette série, je m'appuierai aussi beaucoup sur l'article de 1950 d'Alan Turing,
parce que c'est certainement l'un des articles les plus fous de l'histoire.
Et puis je vous recommande aussi les vidéos que j'ai faites en anglais avec des professeurs de l'EPFL, sur la chaîne ZettaBytes.
J'espère que ce premier épisode en mode un peu "teaser" vous aura vraiment donné envie de voir cette série sur l'intelligence artificielle.
La prochaine fois, on parlera d'intelligence, et on se demandera si une machine peut posséder l'intelligence humaine.
Si vous avez aimé cet épisode, pensez à le liker, à le commenter, à le partager,
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs épisodes. Merci aux tipeurs pour leurs dons
et j'espère que vous serez là les prochaines fois.
*vignette : Cette accélération exponentielle dont je vous parle, la raison pour laquelle vous dis que ça arrive tout de suite, on a du mal à la voir, c'est difficile de la voir
c'est difficile parce que notre cerveau, il fonctionne en mode linéaire :
il a tendance à penser que ce qui va arriver les deux prochaines années, ça arrivera au même rythme que les deux dernières années.
En réalité c'est cumulatif et ça s'accélère à une vitesse exponentielle.
Si on avait dit à nos ancêtres il y a cent ans qu'à l'avenir on serait capables de se parler, se voir dans le creux de la main
à deux endroits de la planète différents, ils nous aurais pris pour des fous.*
*vignette 2 : texte en anglais*